evaluate three and a half minus x when x
is equal to five and x is equal to
negative five so let's start with the
situation where x is equal to five then
this expression becomes
it becomes let me do it so three and a
half
minus and instead of writing an x there
we know that x is equal to five so i'll
put a five right over here now let's
think about it on the number line so let
me draw
a number line i can do a straighter
number line than that
so that's my number line
right there is zero and i have one
two
three
four three and a half sits right in
between three and four so three and a
half is right over there
three and a half and i'm gonna subtract
five and before i do that let me draw
some spaces below zero because this is
obviously a larger number than that so
we're going to drop below zero we're
three and a half to the right and we're
gonna go five to the left so we're gonna
end up to the left of zero let me do
negative one
negative two
and negative three so we're gonna move
five over to the left so let's move one
to the left two to the left let me do
that another color so one to the left
two to the left three to the left four
to the left
five to the left brings us right there
when we just look at it when you just
look at it visually you get to
you get to negative one and a half so
this is negative one and a half which
will be the right answer but let's think
about it a little more to think about
how to come up with it mathematically
instead of having to draw the number
line so three and a half
it's literally three and a half to the
right of zero it's absolute value is
three and a half and of course it's a
positive number so the length this
distance right here is the absolute
value of three and a half
that length
right over there then we are subtracting
5 from that so we're going to move 5 to
the left from this point over here so
we're going to move 5 to the left
from that point over there
let me draw an arrow here just so we
went 5 to the left
so the length of this magenta part is 5.
that is 5. so the number the absolute
value of the number that we care about
is going to be this difference over here
the absolute value of the number we care
about is going to be
this
number right over here which is really
if you just think about its absolute
value it's just the difference between
five and three and a half but since we
are subtracting the larger number it's
going to be
negative and so if you were to just so
you can literally view this
you can say that this is the same thing
as the negative of and we know it's
going to be a negative number because
we're subtracting a larger number from a
smaller number it's the negative of
it's the negative of you take the larger
number five
minus three and a half
five minus three and a half and there's
multiple ways you can do this you could
you do you could probably do this in
your head if it was five minus three you
would get two but if you're if you're
you have to subtract three and then you
have to subtract another half so you'd
get to two and then subtract another
half you would get to one and a half so
five minus three and a half is one and a
half stick the negative out front
negative one and a half
let's do the second part x is equal to
negative five x is equal to negative
five then this expression up here
becomes
three and a half
minus and instead of x we have a
negative 5
minus
negative 5. now a lot of ways this is
easier and this is kind of just
something that hopefully you'll start
it'll almost be a knee-jerk reaction if
you subtract a negative number that is
the exact same thing as adding the
number you these are
addition and subtraction are inverse
operations subtracting a negative number
is the same thing as adding it
so let me put it this way subtracting a
negative is the same thing this is equal
to three and a half
plus you can view these negatives
cancelling out plus five
three and a half plus five and this is
pretty straightforward you don't have to
draw a number line here three and a half
plus five you could view this well
that's just going to be eight and a half
we just added the whole number of parts
i didn't even have to write it as
improper fraction
it's eight
and a half anyway hopefully you found
that helpful